こんにちははじめしゃちょーですついに
食ってしまいました今の技術だとほぼ人の
顔に近いレベルのお面
作れちゃうんですというわけではじめしゃ
ちょーのお面作ってみました
160万円
高いんですけど高いんですけども値段に
見合ったクオリティというかまだちらっと
しか見てないんですけどもあのー
クソ気持ち悪いですクソ気持ち悪い自分の
顔って自分が一番よく見てるからなんか
そのいつも見慣れたものがものとして置い
てあるのはすごい怖いというんですけども
すごいんですよ皆さん最近の技術なんか
もう
相当細かい部分まで
再現されたはじめしゃちょーのお面作って
みましたというわけで早速実物あるので
持っていきたいと思います
[音楽]
気持ち悪からないではいこの中にあります
ちょ待ってマジで
うわー
ごく
動いてなんだなんか3Dスキャナーみたい
なやつでしっかりとな顔全部スキャンされ
て毛穴とかそういう部分まで
完全に
再現させていただきましたこちらが超
リアルなはじめしゃちょーの顔です
やばいやばい
もうここで皆さん察してほしいんすけど
[音楽]
ここでも結構俺っぽくないですかこの時点
でじゃあ行きます
[音楽]
気持ち悪い
気持ち悪いけど
すごい
再現性だな
すごくないですかこれ
俺だな
あー実物の方がイケメンかすごいよこれ
どう見ても俺の顔ですよあんまり自分の顔
が机に置いてあることないと思うんです
けどもこれすごいなあ
やばまつ毛も俺まつ毛長いんですよ結構で
眉毛も結構濃かったりしてこの
靴の感じとかもね完全に
鼻の毛穴とかもすごい目とかマジでリアル
だなこれこっちの目だけこのなんか赤い
なんか跡があったり眉毛の濃さとかも
完全にこれ肌質とかも全て完全再現されて
ます
気持ち悪いいやー
すっごいやだ
違和感ないんじゃない1回自分で自分つけ
てみますね俺付けても変わんないんじゃ
ない
どうですかね
えこれどういつも俺今つけてるんですけど
どうですかどういつなのと変わりますこれ
で違和感なかったらマジでリアル横と感じ
とかもちょっと納得が分からんけど
[音楽]
お面の中に
同じ顔これやばくないすかこんな
えげつないものを作ってしまったんです
けども今回ですね俺の顔を大量に準備し
ましたマズレてるから大量にはじめしゃ
ちょーの顔を準備できたのでだってキモ
すぎでも何だろう
いつも見るから半信感がある今回これだけ
はじめしゃちょーの顔を準備できたという
ことで俺と同じ身長180cm
後半の男性をたくさん準備しましたその男
たちにはじめしゃちょーの顔をつけさせて
みると
[音楽]
完成しました
はじめしゃちょー集団です
[音楽]
というわけでここには
結構身長とか体型が僕に似てる男性を集め
て全員の顔を始め社長にさせていただき
ました皆さん今日は集まっていただいた
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
めっちゃ俺にお辞儀されてるというわけね
今からこのはじめしゃちょーのコピーたち
には3くんのお家で生活してもらいたいと
思いますで
正直遠くから見たり動いてるとロックか
どうか本物かどうかの見分けかなりつか
ないと思うんですよ
俺は俺は仲間たちを信じてる見世物の
はじめしゃちょーが簡単にいてもきっと
きっと俺だって目抜いてくれると思ってる
今日はそんな仲間たちを試してしまうよう
な真似をしてしまうんですけれども大量の
方に社長がいて本物かどうか分かるかどう
かちょっと試してみたいと思いますそれで
は早速始め社長散らばっていきたいと思い
ますでは行こう
僕もバレないように
ウィッグをつけましたこれでみんなと髪型
も一緒です
顔認証と行けるんかな
俺だな
ダメなのかな
[音楽]
ダメなのかななんか無理っぽいですね
はいというわけではじめしゃちょー
セッティング完了しましたいやもうどこ見
ても俺やどこ見てもはじめしゃちょーです
そしてみんなこっち見てます
いやこれすごいなこの中に俺も隠れれば
多分バレないと思うんで
[音楽]
私
気持ち悪い
[音楽]
本物はどれかな
ここは
[音楽]
マジで似てんなぁ
違うわ
[音楽]
絶対違うや
[笑い]
[音楽]
わかんなかったちょっと似てる
本当に
すごいすごいだろう分身したぞ分身だ
リアル
失礼しますね
殴るな
[音楽]
[拍手]
お疲れです
もし
怖い怖い怖い怖い
何
えっ
覚えてるこれ
初めじゃない
え初めて
相当これで高いんですよめちゃめちゃ
コーンギターこの家の3階と4階に大量に
初めて社長がいますちょっと今が大好き君
には
本物のはじめしゃちょーを探してもらい
たいですなるほど
頑張りますお願いしますいやーもう一発で
どうもそれはすごいですよろしくお願いし
ます
[音楽]
よし
うわいっぱいいるなぁ
[音楽]
違う
違う違う
[音楽]
え待って本当にいるんでしょ
いなくない
わかった
君だ
初め
おら
足のね
長さとかねまじここら辺でわかったよそれ
でわかんない何
[音楽]
[拍手]
本物のはじめしゃちょーを探せ
一人しかおらんから
余裕どんだけ見てきてると思ってるはじめ
しゃちょーいやマジで
はじめしゃちょーだけど
どこにいるマジで
えっはじめしゃちょー
怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い
どこどこどこどこどこどこやばいやばい
やばいどうぞ
[音楽]